Well, it is officially that time of the year,
sleigh bells, candy cane and old St. Nick.
But one Houston mom is teaching the importance of
representation this year and is making sure that
all the kids in Texas feel seen this holiday season.
I love this story and this person so much, take a look.
Hi, my name is Megan Butler-Coleman,
and I live in Houston, Texas.
I am the owner and the founder of a company
by the name of The Black Santa Houston.
And I founded the company about three years ago
in 2019 for my son, Luke.
It's amazing how children change your lives.
For me, all I wanted to do was
have an opportunity for Luke to take a photo with Santa
when he was 10 months old.
And little did I realize that
I wasn't actually gonna be able to find
exactly what I was looking for.
A person that was a reflection of my family,
and that had a natural beard.
After a search for more than two years,
when Luke turned almost three years old.
I was able to connect with a very,
very dear friend of mine Oni,
and we were able to start The Black Santa Houston,
and now straight from the north pole,
we have created this amazing experience,
the new tradition in Houston,
where all families have the opportunity to meet a Santa
that is reflection of their family.
And that just provides a little additional Christmas cheer
to a time in which we have a very,
standard image that we usually see of Santa.
But we are allowing for all families
to see themselves through Santa,
through the Black Santa Houston.
Honestly, for me, it's just,
it has to be over the moon
and we honestly want to celebrate
Christmas every day. (chuckles)
(audience cheers)
Megan Butler-Coleman is joining us now via zoom.
Megan, how are you?
Oh my gosh, hi.
I'm so glad, hi (laughs) oh my goodness.
Megan, you are just my hero.
I mean, what started off as a photo session
for your son has grown into something so meaningful
for so many people in the city of Houston.
Please tell us, what your intention was.
Thank you so much, Drew.
I don't know why it wasn't here in Houston
or just available to all the families,
but I'm just so overjoyed and excited
that we were able to create an experience
for families all over Houston,
even in cities beyond and
beyond photos I just have to tell
a very special thank you to our photographer,
because he's able to help capture these moments
and these magical moments with the families
that are just traditions that are lasting.
And now we even have Mrs. Claus joining us.
And so Sandra's on the road.
He's traveling to cities like Colleen, Texas, to hospitals.
We even have families Drew, flying in from Seattle
and Oklahoma, Louisiana,
just to come and have an opportunity
to just have that magical moment.
It just overjoys me, It's just so exciting.
I don't know how this is not a standard norm.
I think what you are doing is so revolutory.
I want to see you expand it beyond Texas.
Thank you for everything you are doing in that state,
but I'm like, how can we help you build this out?
Because what you have built is so incredible.
Thank you Drew.
(audience claps)
It's wonderful.
It's just wonderful.
Thank so much for doing this.
Now, I think it's time actually to meet Santa.
Can we bring him out?
(upbeat music playing)
(audience cheering)
Ho ho ho ho ho.
Drew, Merry Christmas ho ho ho.
Hello, ho ho ho. (laughs)
This organization to me is so groundbreaking
and mind blowing that
I don't know how it's not in every city across the globe.
And how do we get there?
Because you see over 500 children in Houston.
Yes, yes.
And may I ask as
the seed of this most important journey
that you and Megan are doing,
how do we take this all the way?
Because it's just so important.
Drew, actually it is the joy of the magic of Christmas.
We want to have our families to have traditions
that they love.
And part of that tradition is to have our kids
to take pictures with Santa.
So that's some of the things
that we've talked to Megan about,
and that's something that we've been doing
for just three years, but it's getting bigger and bigger.
And it's so much more than the picture.
It's a tradition that families really value.
(audience claps)
This means so much to me.
And you've had such a big impact on the city of Houston.
What have you learned from that model
that we think we can take elsewhere?
Drew, I've learned that we have to make sure
that kids at a very young age,
they begin to see images of themselves,
regardless of their color, race, or creed.
That's very important.
So when kids say,
"Mommy, I wanna be a doctor."
"Daddy, I want to be a teacher."
When they see those images really young,
it's a reflection that they can actually be that one day.
So the sooner they start to see those images,
the sooner they can know that they can actually do it
and they can become exactly what they want to be.
(audience claps)
If you see it,
you can be it.
Absolutely.
Now, I hear you do so much charity work
and have a local outreach program coming.
So I would love to let you know
that we want to give you guys $5.000
to help,
Ho ho ho ho.
By choice, for all the kids.
(audience claps)
We thank you and love you so much Drew
for what you're doing,
for helping us to spread the word
of how important diversity is in a diverse world.
I am in awe
of what you guys do.
(audience claps)
It is an honor to talk about your program
and let me help expand it.
Thank you Santa.
Thank you Drew.
And thank you Megan.
I can't wait to do more.
Happy holidays, we'll be right back.
(upbeat music playing)